I've always tried to incorporate some
kind of social aspect into what I do the
robotics on my current venture might
sound the most impersonal in the group
but robotics is kind of transforming the
way we live the way we work and I would
argue for the better one of the
observations that led me to come back to
Pittsburgh let me to come Carnegie
Mellon was it any time a new industry
emerged as kind of commercially relevant
whether it's biotech enterprise software
the internet all the way back to the PC
you know a new geography and a new kind
of group of players tended to emerge as
the leaders and I think pittsburgh has
the formula to be that in robotics I
think maybe one thing to note in terms
of resources then is just how much
Carnegie Mellon's not shut itself off
the mix of perspectives that didn't
exist anywhere else in the planet where
I am right now couldn't have happened
when I Carnegie Mellon its people in the
venture community is people in these
kind of industry focused areas actually
coming back to campus and participating
through you know short Center events or
through tepper avancer through the
robotics Institute events and that very
thin barrier between the University and
all its resources and then what's around
here which is just as impressive is
really helpful the quality programs at
Carnegie Mellon is the people it's the
fact they interact with each other it's
the fact that there is this more
community spirit here that's really
important and really helpful in starting
the business
you